it does sound very gently remember the
two things away comparing he our
extended form which in fact you can see
a whole bunch of numbers here that
written in expanded form and index form
which is kind of like our abbreviation
and well you know what to say five times
I just live you want to say something a
bit more three right so remember that
this is shorthand it's an abbreviation
for please written it down it was
confident with there is yeah that's very
good
seven times seven times seven now you
don't have to write this bit down but
you may remember back when you learned
about the first level of multiplication
was way backwards right you may have
learned that multiplication is about a
deep things over and over again
do you remember that right it's kind of
like this is what you don't have to
write if you write five plus five is
five but that's fine but you don't
that's okay because three times what if
I had to write it like a few more times
and a few more times and a few more
times it rapidly gets a bit boring right
why don't you say at least in this case
five times right so I would say that is
five times I might owe multiplication is
kind of like addition but like a whole
bunch of them together well that's
exactly what's happening with this index
right to notice that that came decks are
they're powered that was the other word
we learned part is kind of like
multiplication all over again just like
multiplication is addition or excellent
so there's the first one how can rewrite
the second one in expanded form and he
taking someone who's thinking yeah
yep very good
fantastic so you can see we're just
stringing them along it's no big deal
and you can see also why it's called
expanded for they've got new big guard
takes more time to write okay well us
once somebody hasn't seen yep good and
we do it five times very good and so you
can see did I do the right number times
yes you can see why we introduced index
phone because it's a little bit tiresome
to go over yet so therefore let's
transition to this next bit what do we
do to work out what the index should be
yeah very good
so I count one two three which means I
should write five with a three at the
top and that's the index or power
okay very good I'm sold is it offered an
answer yet the next one two to the power
4
perfect okay this one he cambria very
good now the last one's a bit of a
curveball and that's why I made the last
one does anyone want to offer a
suggestion somebody hasn't said anything
yet Kimmy go okay so there's a few
different ways to write this one and
it's a bit sneaky so I'm actually going
to give you a few different ones right
let's go with this one first so I go 1
million that's six zeros isn't it and ^
one that is in index for business
because index looks a kind of it that's
a fine answer this someone suggested
another one Eric okay now you got
straight right to the young went to the
smallest one do you notice there's one
two three four five six zeroes right
which if you remember back to at less
than we did on strategies for
multiplication if you want to multiply
something by 10 you just how does your
own music you remember that so here I've
added 60
yes so it's like I multiply by 10 1 2 3
4 5 6 times okay now if you did your
homework there was a table where you
were filling out up hundreds thousands
thousands hundred thousands and so on if
you had them all there and this is the
way you can write all of them meaning
they're cool okay so if you didn't catch
that one that's a right but now you can
redeem it by the way just before we
leave it this is in fact not the only
pair of ways I can write a million with
index 4 I'm going to let you like think
about it for me because a few of you I
think of comment on but I wouldn't know
if you have that thought circulating
around you can now say at the end of a
lesson a few of the other ways to do it
because there are a few others